le monde sait ce que neuf magasins comme
ça squeeze un jeune chiot se trouve non
pas sur un seul jeu mais sur plusieurs
jeux c'est parti le premier jeu
s'appelle donc de szczesny wind et ce
menu et d'extrêmement moche alors all
star tu sais que ça c'est bon donc
l'adjoint d'un sacré délire quoi ok
d'accord en fait l'histoire c'est que
cette fille à droite vont se battre
aussi une figure enfin bref veut une une
glace et son père veut pas voyager mais
à l'air très méchant et du coup je dois
faire des têtes pour qu'il accepte
voilà par exemple cette tête ce à quoi
je suis dans son papa s'il te plaît j'ai
un temps pour reproduire la salorge
désolé moi je suis ma fille fait cette
tête judo judo dessus tu as quoi j'ai
emmené à l'hôpital dans la foulée non
non non non il me dit oh la tête qu'il
faut faire attention face une table tout
choquée aux ménages mais avec ces
perthus et chaque tapis a là un gros
problème quoi lui dire non non non pour
une place mais quelque chose [ __ ] mais
je comprends rien touche longue à chaque
touche correspond à un muscle mais
[ __ ] qu'est ce que c'est dur à trouver
fail mais qu'est ce que ça peut faire
quelque chose
papa je voulais dessiner de mocheté je
m'en bats les steaks
bon il faut pourtant wayne glace mais
bon elle pouvait passer la glace aussi
aux pierrots oui la bouche comme ça on
garde à temps
tu donnes dirait qu'une classe tu peux
les mettre dans la bouche avec une
mouche paris non mais quoi non non non
non on va durer plusieurs papa je t'aime
et veut pas pas encore [ __ ] quoi je
voulais que tu joues à la barbichette
regard j'avais fait un bon menton pour
toi voilà olala mais non mais non mais
non
je crois que c'est ça le truc il a
appris en fait non non non non non simin
clacs et je lui transperce à la dragon
ball j'ai tué mon père si vous pensez
qu'un jour on va y arriver
alors oui quelle tête faut faire bas
aucune tête faut rien faire faut juste
rapprocher ses sourcils un peu un peu
comme ça adore j'ai bien fait la
highlander trop d'espoir au sébasto que
le pen fille en tout cas quoi bouder
cède pas il veut acheter une glace
vraiment [ __ ] comme ça c'est mieux
un même si rien n'a changé mais tu vois
bien quel en train de mourir plus tard
devenu la glace mais alors où est tu
clak quelqu'un d'aussi bosch quoi
attendre c'est bon là bas je donne une
gaze direct sur quelqu'un essaie
peut-être win
il va donner la glace yes à tanger en
train de lécher m'agace tranquillement
un vrai que mon père me regardes quoi tu
m'en passer un peu non ok le deuxième je
sais boxe tu gagnes
d'après les images que j'ai vues ça
avait l'air vraiment bien on peut le
voir la tronche de cette fille déjà que
ça a l'air d'être un jeu un peu chelou
bois c'est parti on a je le fais
agresser par une voix off tout va bien
très bien alors c'est ça le jeu oh c'est
choquant à temps mais ça faisait juste
dix années que j'ai pas le jeu comme ça
quoi il ya aucune mesure 3d c'est juste
des images
regarde là il se cacher derrière ideo
avec son deuil et dégueulasse je te vois
ne me supporte pas tous ses députés à
partir de là il y avait plus de plus un
guide
les sursis vidéo mais je dois faire quoi
simulateur de nos concrétions quoi ce
jeu concours est bien d'accord m un gros
problème
j'ai ce qu'il nous faut pour remonter le
moral unicorn senpai slap a probablement
le jeu avec le gameplay le plus
pertinent du monde voilà nous avons une
mare ont beau et nous mettons des
claques à une petite licorne et elle
aime ça à plat avant les skis il va
tenter four en fait c'est bien ces biens
brab est celle la bravade sert à
chauffer la voix off des primes
totalement quoi l a10 au sun enfin petit
beau ou pas vas-y passe en dessous les
mots y met des points plus tard allait
elle est mort tu portes fin septembre
ces imposteurs tu n'es plus d'être tué à
au revoir on voit là encore dave on
pense fort à toi c'est promis tu es
parti dans une si belle explosion par
tout internaute cherche texte taillé ou
études à yves nom tellement tu as raté
qu'est ce que c'est que ces simulateurs
de superbad bidon quoi il ya vu la
crèche de la vidéo il ya tous les petits
cris de la bio qui vole un caddie quoi
qui faisait ses courses d'un avion
désolé désolé pardon mais sans déconner
tu peux sauver des shorts eu les chocs
de bayer ag superman je sauve personne
jusqu'à ce mois passé gérants car assez
la fin your name taille nous t'aimerons
toujours
voilà messieurs d'accord juste exposer
les jours à distance [ __ ] mais
superman était gentil quoi dans je
t'aime tellement tu vas tellement keisei
une petite pensée pour la cape de
superman qui est en fait à la machine à
laver et en attendant il a pris son drap
rouge sur lequel il a marqué s en mode
dégueulasse daigle on ne m'attend sur
timberman qui le fait que la pudeur le
mieux foutu auxquels j'ai pu jouer voilà
c'est tout con vous allez voir et ses
meilleurs agents tout comme le bieber
des jeux d'été assez brutale je ne sais
pas où tu me manques
le but c'est de couper l'arbre voilà de
la sorte et d'éviter brangeois par
exemple ah si je coupe à gauche encore
bab je me prends la branche et je meurs
déjà ce mec-là peu près 100 kilos pour 1
mètre 90 donc je vois pourquoi il mourir
à cause d'une petite branche l'idée
voilà pourquoi pourquoi [ __ ] et le but
c'est d'aller le plus haut possible ce
que voyait une barre et si j'arrête de
couper du bois la barre des 100 voilà du
coup tu presses même cantal tant que
moyen ont franchi des niveaux
mais voilà et humeurs comme ça comme un
gros con finalement le temps change
derrière c'est très beau à la voit
notamment des pseudos volet voilée à
cause de je me prends le branche [ __ ]
d'oiseaux plusieurs saisons sont
disponibles y aura notamment un dlc dans
lequel on pourra
j'ai de chemise c'est quoi ah ben voilà
bah le dlc déjà sorti [ __ ] en vrai
j'ai découvert ça y est hmm pas que l'on
pouvait changer de chef georges et
d'évoquer quoi on se dit [ __ ] mais
c'est beau gosse oui oui je veux bien
lui les branches le tuer a pas de
problème les fermes et de 50 pour 20 kg
est attendu par tous au théâtre en bo1
les oiseaux pas cette fois
bon cette fois les oiseaux donc son
mignon je veux qu'ils aient passion du
jeu désolé je viens de le mettre sous
contrat sont adressés par le personnel
puis style du monde savait surtout et
hamas de tac tac tac tac tac tac tac tac
tac tac
ah mais non mais non non non mais j'ai
fait 225 je serai jamais quand j'ai
appuyé j'ai fait nouveau j'avais oublié
j'avais oublié ce que ça faisait de
jouer un jeu comme ça où tu continues ou
tu causes des jouets mettant aucun
plaisir [ __ ] mais comment ils font
pour nous mettre dans cet état sans
déconner est ce qu'on parle
éventuellement de la taille de cet arbre
ça détail à prendre en compte c'est
aussi de cette fois il est l'heure
d'aller plus haut
ne jugez pas et vous l'avions s'est dit
au point de s'élever de quelque chose
j'ai envie de voter pour faire une
petite compilation si ça vous a fini ce
n'est pas allé mais ça fera vraiment
plaisir pour 114 2 nouvelles vidéos
comme d'habitude toutes les semaines
tous les mois toutes les années que le
siècle 1
mais je vais décider un jour où il n'y
aura plus de vidéos à ce moment-là
hashtag triste #owni hashtag yes hashtag
je déteste le monde dise